more than two dozen people are facing
charges in an alleged scheme to
illegally dope racehorses
Jason service was the most prominent
individual indicted yesterday in federal
court he's the trainer of maximum
security that's the horse that finished
first in last year's Kentucky Derby but
was disqualified for interference
services accused of administering drugs
to that horse and others in order to
make them run faster his attorney did
not immediately respond to our request
for comment trainers veterinarians and
drug distributors are also among those
indicted there is no evidence that these
charges are connected to the recent
racehorse deaths at the Santa Anita
isn't that the horse that recently won
the largest purse it's seven million
dollars yeah the Saudi Cup that's right
there's no case they say service they
gave performance-enhancing drugs to
every horse under his control
yeah I mean look if there's doping in
human sports is gonna be doping in horse
related sports as well you know given to
the racehorses in an effort to increase
their performance beyond their natural
abilities also to improve the horses
performance because they were sensitive
to pain which led to horse fracture
they're a cascading effects or two if
one trainer thinks the other trainer is
doing it then they feel like they have
to do with lodge that's what happened in
baseball during the bike racing yeah and
this is a 100 billion dollar industry
and we're talking about yeah